welcome to the heavyspoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the biggest flash in
the pan on YouTube in this video we're
going to be breaking down the Super Bowl
trailer for The Flash packed with Easter
eggs plot details and a lot of things
that connect to the comics this upcoming
movie has a lot of things going on with
it that we need to talk about and the
movie's been hit with numerous delays
ever since its Inception and there's
been a number of directors attached to
it it's also been pushed back several
times but it looks like it came out at
the right Point as it's now being used
as a device to reset the universe
flashpoint was a major event in the
comics that streamlined the continuity
and in them Barry Allen went back in
time and saved his mother from being
murdered unfortunately bad thing this
sent out a ripple effect across the
universe that caused a number of things
to happen differently for example Bruce
got shot in the alley instead of his
parents and this is Dad became Batman
and his mother became the Joker Superman
didn't land in Kansas and he was
captured by the government and Atlantis
went to war with their mascara in the
end flash went back and allowed his
mother pass away and this created The
New 52 continuity in it there were some
stories kept some reckoned and allowed
DC to have a soft reboot that's sort of
what's happening in this universe with
James Gunn using it as a way to take
certain elements of the DCU but start
again with a new continuity
tell me something
you can go anywhere
another timeline
Another Universe
so why do you want to stay
fight to save this one
because this is the world where my mom
lives
I'm not gonna lose her again
[Music]
now we start off the teaser with Barry
arriving at his house and look at the
guy's face you can actually see tears in
his eyes it suits emanating with energy
so I'm guessing that this is a moment
where he's just traveled back in time
however it could just be him revisiting
his old house remembering what happened
there and then this pushes him on the
mission to go back it in the past we
then cut to a shot which I'm guessing is
the rooftop of Wayne Manor and in the
distance we can see Gotham City now
Wayne Manor will be returning from
Batman 89 and this is actually nebweb
house located in England this was
changed for Batman Returns but they've
brought it back for this movie the
Gargoyles are exactly the same and you
might recognize this from also appearing
recently in you season 4. in the first
teaser for the film we saw Barry arrive
there in a Yellow Cab and the license
numbers on it could be a reference to
the lodge Universe the plate reads 820a
with a number possibly being a reference
to when flash traveled back in time to
witness his own origin in 1982. OA is
the home of the Green Lanterns and we
know that there's been plans for a while
now to make them part of the service
shout outs to ryanairy for pointing that
out and also that the taxi number is 163
which was the issue that Barry Allen
first met the reverse flash reverse
flash is obsessed with Barry and he
traveled back in time from the future to
kill him but instead he murdered his
mother we also know that Barry's house
number will be 12 and this is where
Barry met a version of himself who was
revealed to be the dark flash Barry in
the movies meaning another version of
himself and we know from the Funko Pops
in the film that dark flash will feature
in it so it's Theory time
so I think that the second Barry Allen
is probably going to be that version of
The Flash we know that he dons the
Michael Keaton batsu and it gets turned
red so he can become the character he
clearly isn't The Flash in this universe
which is why he makes a costume like
this and he may not even have his powers
yet when Barry comes across him it seems
like he doesn't have a clue what's going
on and if he was the flash he'd kind of
be aware of what his abilities are
therefore I think that when Barry
travels back in time he comes across
this older version himself just before
the experiment later on we see a
lightning bolt passing through Barry and
going into the other one which I'm
guessing is when they recreate the
experiment that created his powers in
the first place also there's a split
second shot one of the sandstorms in
which you can catch the dark Flash and
this seems to be going down when Zod
attacks so therefore I'm guessing that
the second Barry get his powers they
turn wild God of control and he doesn't
know how to wield them this then creates
a dark flash he then travels through
time and lots of time you want me wibbly
wobbly stuff anyway that's in a few
times you
ah stop me up
stop me up and stop me up I never stop
and from here we could do a shot of
Michael Keaton's bat suits sprawled out
on the floor you can tell it's his
because in the background it's got the
yellow chest emblem and the boots also
look identical to his there's blood
dripping from the cowl and this is very
reminiscent of a moment from The Dark
Knight Returns in which Batman goes back
to the cave he slowly strips off walks
into the darkness and accepts that the
bat has him and it forever will it's
very metaphorical it's not like a big
well it is a big bat but yeah it's very
much him accepting that he can't stop
being Batman now from here we get a shot
of Batman from behind riding on a bat
bike a lot of people have speculated
that this is Christian Bale but this is
actually Ben Affleck's version just
riding on some different Tech he has a
blue and gray suit some of the comics
and they've finally done it they finally
done the Blue and Gray in Live Action
now the bike itself has double front
wheels and this is actually based on the
one from Batman White Knight it's such a
cool design an absolutely brilliant
graphic novel and I definitely recommend
that you pick it up if you haven't read
it all already he's chasing after a
convoy and I'm guessing that this
happens early on in the movie before
Barry breaks time this also looks like
it might be taking place in England or
Scotland at the very least and I
recognize those those signs and those
street lights anyways we're back baby
and from here we go to Barry on the
phone and you can see the little flash
ring on his finger this actually houses
his suit just like in the comics and
later on we see it folding around his
finger seems to be depressed reaching
out to someone and this could be Ben
Affleck's version of Batman who he talks
to later in the trailer we then catch
him arriving at what I'm guessing is
carrying on from the chase scene and go
on mate you've got Batman out there on a
bike when you can you could just run up
the trucks and catch him in a second you
lazy
now amongst this we got little Montage
shots including an explosion and what
I'm guessing are super girls feet now as
for Supergirl I do think that she's
gonna be along the same lines as how
Superman was in the original Flashpoint
in that they discovered him far on the
ground and it was a similar scene to how
we see Supergirl later if you look at
her body not like that you dirty pervert
you will see that she's very under
malnourished and this is because
Superman and kryptonians in general feed
off UV lights from the Sun this gives
them their power and in both the book in
this movie it looks like when they reach
the surface they're finally getting
charged up if you think back to the new
casino in Batman v Superman you'll
remember that after the explosion went
off clock looked very drained and it was
only upon the sunlight reaching him that
he started to charge up this was also
pulled from The Dark Knight Returns in
which a nuke went off in that and
Superman managed to power himself off by
getting the sunlight from sunflowers not
joking that's how it happens and yeah
I'm guessing that a similar thing is
going to be happening here later on we
see her emerging in a white prison
jumpsuit and I'm guessing it comes off
the back of this moment I actually think
that there might be 7 timelines crossing
over with each other and the time you
why me wibbly wobbly stuff has caused
universes to bleed into each other this
could lead to Supergirl being the one
who was taken in by the government
rather than clock she may replace Clark
in this universe and that's why the S on
her chest looks the same as the one that
Clark has a Man of Steel she clearly
come from the same Krypton and it's
possible that she may have landed before
Clark did originally in the comic she
was sent out before him so she she may
have landed on Earth First I'm not doing
Theory time again for that I've already
ruined it time has a pattern
that it can't help reliving
different people different worlds
drawn to each other like
magnets
[Music]
my face so my face now next we see Barry
in his kitchen dancing with his mother
these are very happy moments shot in a
yellow glow before we cut to the harsh
blue reality of her dying in his
father's arms no longer got Billy Kern
up which is a bit of a shame but the guy
had scheduling conflicts so he's not
returning for the film I actually think
that what we're seeing here is two
different realities one in which his
mother died and one in which he didn't
the yellow one is the happy version that
never dealt with her death or as the
blue one is how it played out in the
main Universe yellow is also something
like the second character Dons later on
so I think when they're tying it back to
this moment and showing how the two
realities split off yellow and blue are
Colors that appear throughout the
trailer and we have the one flash that
has blue lightning bolts whereas the
other has yellow yellow is also the
color of the reverse flash and I'm
though I'm getting a bit deep on the
theories here I think they're
telegraphing that point now we watch
Barry racing through the streets and
also get a moment where his younger
Salve runs out into one the Knight
changes and Barry talks about time
warmers being like a loop and there will
be several universe is where this has
played out before you could be traveling
back to that moment reliving it in his
mind and then deciding to change things
because he's now got the ability to it
of course killed his mother his father
got put in jail for it and it very much
destroyed the character's life we then
see a character touching a photo of
their family the hand to me looks like
an older man it's slightly bruised up
and there are Cuts around the fingers
and Knuckles he's also wearing a
cardigan and there's a shot where we see
someone from behind wearing this this
person has long gray hair and I'm
guessing that this is how they find
Bruce Wayne he's touching a photo of the
family he lost and this is then murdered
in a photo that the flash has I think
bruising this movie is very much going
to be a driving force that's like look
if I could go back in time and change
things I would and this will very much
Inspire Barry to do the same thing and
that far that we see in the Flash's room
hasn't grown up so this is clearly him
entering the timeline in which his
mother never died he approaches her from
behind and I'd love it if we just had a
little moment where he's like not
revealing that he's from another
timeline and they'll have this moment
where she doesn't really know what's
going on on but he's going to see his
mother again I can imagine it's going to
be sort of like what happened in
Avengers end game with Thor returning to
frigger and we'll get this very much
heart to heart scene in which he gets to
see what his mother would have been like
if she had grown older now Teddy catches
himself with yellow headphones and a
yellow hoodie and again might be
telegraphing that this is the Royals
flash if you were to go into the past
you have no idea what the consequences
can be Bruce I could fix things you
could also destroy everything just kept
me happening
really broke the universe
inside we've been waiting for you
I created a world with no metahumans
and now there's no one to defend us
want some help
[Music]
you're you are yeah
I'm Batman now from here we go to Barry
and Barry going out to Wayne Manor in
the original Flashpoint buck when Barry
was in the alternate timeline he was
very much like what the hell is going on
wait I know I'll go and ask Batman upon
arriving at the Manor he found Thomas
Wayne there instead and the guy beat the
crap out of him before he convinced him
he was a time traveler Barry didn't have
his powers in that Universe because his
origin story was completely different
and thus they had to recreate the
experiment that made him which we see
playing out here this clearly gives the
other Barry his powers too but whether
it's a good thing remains to be seen as
I was saying before that Batman could
convince him to go back into the past we
do hear Ben Affleck saying all the
warnings that come with time travel he
says he could destroy the timeline but I
do think he'll come around and sort of
see things from Barry's side however he
brings this warning with him and sadly
we know that we're now losing Ben
Affleck he was originally meant to have
a cameo in Aquaman too but we know that
this has been scrapped and For Better or
Worse James Gunn's going in a New
Direction I am actually surprised that
their scrap things like Man of Steel
through Buddha when this movie is so
clearly reliant on it this is shown by
the next scene in which we see zod's
warning going at now judging by the
timeline here I'm guessing that the rest
of the movie takes place in the same
time that Man of Steel happened I don't
know how it's all gonna work out as in
Man of Steel Zod only came to Earth
because Clark accidentally sent out a
beacon but here it's happening and we
can see zod's warning being issued we
found out that Clark's been erased from
the timeline and instead we have super
girls so zod's probably looking for her
instead but how he got the info to
travel to earth we don't know in the
movie better explain it or I'm kicking
off now we see the world engine
attacking and this is of course a
massive moment in Man of Steel however I
actually think that this is Barry
remembering it rather than it happening
in the movie and he's gonna be warning
the citizens of Earth exactly why they
shouldn't trust the kryptonians in Man
of Steel they were quite cordial with
them early on and they had the meeting
with them in the desert which we see
playing at this is where they handed
over clock during Man of Steel but here
I think they're mounting an offensive to
stop them before things get worse your
these are busting out the bite from his
wrist and you might remember that this
is what he used to stab Jarrell the two
flashes are teaming up they're probably
getting Supergirl at this point and
they're finally defeating Zod before
things get out of control and going back
to that theory with the whole Man of
Steel thing before maybe when they freed
Cara that's what sent out the Beacon to
zard and this is how he knows to travel
down to earth Kara is related clock and
potentially he died back on Krypton but
Zod still carries his Grudge for the
house of L and we next hear Barry
talking about how he's created a world
with no meta humans it is still Batman
but beyond that it doesn't seem like
there's any super powered people we
catch him walking up to what I'm
guessing is to stand for the bat suit
and then a crumpled up Superman suit
lying on the floor this likely belongs
to Kara and this explains how she got it
in the movie we catch her slumped over
bones sticking out of her back and you
can also see her Rib Cage being starved
of the sun has completely stripped her
of all her muscles however when she gets
outside it all comes back now we then
get Barry powering up the Batcave this
looks identical to the one from from
1989 including the giant walkway which
is now fitted with light if you cast
your mind back to Batman 1989 Vicki Vale
got out and almost stepped over the edge
and it was very it was very very
dangerous at Batman so I'm glad you've
lit it properly now held in safety is a
big thing and and maybe put a railing
around there you never know when you're
gonna run into trouble now from here we
go to a shot that we have already seen
before however they've added in the
Batwing this looks in line with the 1989
version and it's in a section of the
cave that we've never seen before at
this point we get the most on the nose
fan service moment I've ever seen you
are yeah
I'm Batman I don't think they've ever
played it like this before where
character literally walks up to the
camera stares directly into it and says
I'm Batman should have just said and now
Batman Returns because his moments you
know what it's ridiculous but or the
first time I watched it especially I was
like I'm loving it it's amazing it's
amazing but yeah thinking about it how
it's been worked in the movie you know
it is a bit on the nose and it's sort of
the equivalent of Iron Man coming back
and just walking up to the camera and
going I am Iron Man it's that sort of
thing it's very very very very low bro I
don't think it's gonna win Scorsese back
around the comic book movies but you
know what all those fans out there
who've been wedding so long for this to
happen I think they're all gonna hit the
roof now the TV spot had some extra
moments in it and we also got the top
being pulled off the Batmobile so we
could finally see what it looks like
looks exactly the same as it did so no
big surprises there but we also got some
additional bat suits some of these are
gray and blue this there's ones with
guns under the armpits scuba diving ones
ones with goggles that might even be the
nightmare timeline version and lots of
different things that really make this
moment pop in the back you can also
catch a bad seat with a damaged bat
symbol on it and if you cast your mind
back to Batman 89 this is how the suit
looked at the end of it really nice
bring that across and I love seeing this
moment with all the different costumes
now for the next part we see Batman
jumping down and kicking the crap out of
some thugs couldn't be completely honest
put your finger over the dislike button
um I was taking a bit out of this Moment
by how bad I thought the CGI looked
don't know just something about a 70
year old man jumping down and moving
like this it just sticks out as being a
natural to me and it did take me a bit
out of the trailer now they had
basically two options to do they they
could do a fight like in the Irish man
when we see Robert De Niro kicking the
crap out of someone or they could go
over the top with it like what we see
here clearly they went with a better
route but to me at this moment it just
Falls flat because in the back of my
mind I have this is a 70 year old guy
doing things that we've never seen him
do before I do kind of wish they kept it
more grounded that's my opinion on it if
you disagree yeah that's fine you know
what I won't hate you if I ever as long
as you don't hate me now we then cut to
a shot of Supergirl carrying what I'm
guessing is Barry she does this during
what appears to be a storm and
potentially he lost his powers and needs
to charge back up from here we go to a
hospital and can see a large part of the
ground collapsing if you look in the top
left corner you can see this is the
Martha Wayne Institute and this is of
course tied in with Bruce Wayne this
probably happens at the start of the
movie with Ben Affleck's version as it
seems like that sort of setting and that
could lead into the chase with anchored
to Barry running up the side of a
skyscraper and it shows just how fast
the character is you can defy gravity
because he's moving faster than the
forces and it enables him to run along
walls now we then see Batman drop down
and he pops out of batarang this is
identical to the way it appeared in 1989
and it's so cool seeing this brought
back now within kitabarian what seems
like a convenience store with a woman
touching his face going back to being a
hand expert the hand does look slightly
older doesn't it I'm guessing that this
is his mother over the top of this Barry
talks about how he has to change things
back and in Flashpoint unfortunately he
had to let his mother die that could
potentially be what's happening here and
he's saying goodbye to his mother before
he inevitably causes her death this will
set things back to normal and it's such
a heartbreaking thing for the character
to have to do we then get the boots
watching and what such a cool moment and
if you look on the left this is actually
the repurposed one from Batman's suit as
the same front as what Michael keatons
does and that yellow lightning bolt was
spray painted on now we then go to
Barry's room and I'm guessing that this
is him convincing his past self that
they have to kill his mother bit of an
awkward conversation uh so yeah look
look at that in the corner Pacific Rim
poster nice we then see the Batwing
charging up some electricity and I'm
guessing that this ties over from the
Supergirl shot from before Kara then
smashes sudden the face I get the like
button and we see the battle playing out
in the desert there's that extra Flash
and Barry at one point tries to attack
them we then cut the barium Batman's
Rescue Mission and can see Supergirl
busting out everyone Batman even goes to
punch someone she takes the Kill from
that smacks him in the face and I'm
guessing that's gotta hurt these are
people who've kept her captive for years
and starved her and it's gonna be such a
badass moment watching her finally get
revenge she then introduces herself at
Wayne Manor and if you look behind the
berries you can see Michael Keaton
standing there from here we get the logo
and then in on a joke in which they talk
about how they have to show this to
their kids Supergirl looks great really
nice teaser love the Batwing as well and
yeah that closes it out now for the next
part of the video I want to talk about
some of the rumored plot leaks
circulating about the film including
what the ending is supposed to be if you
don't want to know then check out now
and thanks for sticking with me
obviously full spoilers head from this
point on and if you've been enjoying the
video so far then please hit the Thumbs
Up Button if this video gets 50 likes
I'll take a shower and make sure you
subscribe for videos like this every day
now originally the leaks for the movie
said that the flash ended up going back
in time to let his mother's murder
happen the same way it did originally
not only did he pick up the son of the
air award but this then apparently
opened up several Branch timelines that
we saw him traveling back through
according to the report he traveled back
through the speed force and saw flashes
of Christopher Reeve other versions of
Batman and so on and so forth he was
meant to return home to find the Batman
of his Universe was still Michael Keaton
and that Supergirl was there instead of
Superman the movie apparently ended with
Ben Affleck's voice being heard with him
saying that they were out there in
Another Universe and that Barry had to
say them now in real life we had the
whole thing with Black Adam and Henry
Cavill coming back but this was of
course scrap with the announcement of
the DCU Keaton's appearance in Batgirl
ended with the movie being canceled and
Ben Affleck's Paul was said to have been
removed from this along with his bit in
Aquaman 2. this kind of squashed the
rumors that Affleck was going to be back
as the main Universe Batman taking over
Keaton and knows what DC were doing
but since then James Gunn's announced
his DCU and different rumors have come
out it's been reported by Grace Randolph
that an old Batman act is returning to
Cameo at the end of the movie instead no
she didn't let on exactly who this was
she did tease it was one of these three
while kelma has unfortunately had a
number of health problems George Clooney
is over 60. well and so as well Kilmer
and his Batman wasn't exactly loved and
thus everyone's assumed it's Christian
Bale however since then another of
scoopers and leakers have said it's
George Clooney and that we will be
seeing the bat nipples in a fun Cameo
come the end of the movie James gonna
said that the DCU actor will be a new
one but according to the leaks the film
will end with Cooney being thought out
of the cooler and bringing a cameo that
frees up the flash to travel into any
timeline that he wants now that's all my
thoughts on it the first time I watched
it you know it had those High moments
and then those bitter took me out like
Batman busting up people in that CGI
scene I know I'm sounding like a hater
but I am really on board with this movie
and you can see why they're pushing it
as one of the best comic book films of
all time that's what I'm constantly
hearing from screenings and it has the
potential to be one of the biggest films
this year now I'm very Bittersweet on it
as I don't want to see the Snyder verse
go and sort of tear enough thinking
about the last time we'll see Ben
Affleck poor guy he's now working at
Dunkin Donuts lost all his money and I'm
here for you Ben if you ever need a
shoulder to cry on they're also of
course tying in heavily with Man of
Steel and
I don't know seeing this it's it's all a
bit weird because we know it's getting
wiped now I am very excited for the film
still I'm hoping this is a good send-off
to that universe and obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts in the comments
below thank you for bearing with me I am
losing my voice I had to record a 40
minute Last of Us video the other day
and I don't think I've recovered since
then had it cold for for about three
months um because it could send the kids
to nursery and they're just always
bringing home diseases
and yeah hopefully this hasn't ruined
the video for you and thanks for
sticking with me if you want something
else to watch we've got the Guardians
trailer on screen right now and I hope
to see you over there other way thanks
for clicking the video I've been poor
you take care of yourself and enjoy the
rest of your week peace